vaccinations are at the center of the
biden administration's strategy to end
the pandemic to that end the white house
made january 4 the deadline for larger
companies to get their workers
vaccinated or implement weekly testing
it could affect 84 million workers
nearly three-quarters of america's
workforce some republican governors have
already threatened to sue over the
measure ed o'keefe has been following
this for us at the white house ed good
morning good morning to you nate happy
friday the potential legal blowback is
mounting despite recent polling that
shows most americans support these kind
of mandates and the white house is
defending the new rule saying it's just
all about keeping american workers safe
as mandates continue to be a flash point
across the country the labor department
thursday announced it's implementing a
new vaccination rule requiring companies
with 100 or more employees to get their
workers fully vaccinated by january 4th
or test them for covet 19 at least once
a week fines for not complying could
reach nearly 14 thousand dollars per
worker per violation we know that
vaccines absolutely save lives
and we know that mandates work with
cases rising or holding steady in at
least 27 states the white house says the
mandate is about maximizing compliance
how confident is the white house these
will hold up in court with a lot of gop
states threatening legal action
so we're pretty we're pretty confident
the administration clearly has the
authority to protect workers on capitol
hill some senators said more mandates
are not the answer it's probably the
most frightening ultimatum
that businesses have had to contend with
it's essentially
an unfunded mandate kevin grigg is an
engineering and consulting firm ceo
based in connecticut i think it's going
to take months for
all of us
to figure out exactly how this is going
to work and during that period of time
at least
we're going to have a lot of sunken
costs
some other business leaders say they're
going to wait to see how this all plays
out in the courts but some of the
nation's biggest labor unions and
business groups like the u.s chamber of
commerce are endorsing the new mandates
and private companies are taking their
own steps the ford motor company for
example says all of its 32 000 u.s
workers have to be vaccinated by
december 8.
tony
all right ed thank you very much